OUTNUMBERED.
THANK YOU.
BILL COULDN'T MAKE IT ANY EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND.
ADMINISTRATIONS OFFICIALS SAY
EVERYTHING IS UNDER CONTROL.
HERE IS JAKE SULLIVAN.
>> WE DO HAVE ESTIMATES OF HOW
MANY ENCOUNTERS THERE ARE AT THE
BORDER.
WE BELIEVE THAT SYSTEM IS A
SYSTEM THAT DOES AN EFFECTIVE
JOB OF BEING ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHO IS COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
AND WHAT THE RIGHT WAY TO DEAL
WITH THEIR CASE IS.
>> ARE THERE CONCERNS OVER THE
TITLE 42 EXPIRATION?
>> WE'RE TAKING STEPS TO BE ABLE
TO MANAGE THE EXPIRATION OF
TITLE 42 AND PUT IN PLACE A
PROCESS THAT WILL BE ORDERLY AND
HUMANE.
WE BELIEVE THAT IN DOING SO WE
CAN PROTECT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS.
>> Harris: HE BETTER BE RIGHT.
THE COVER OF THE "NEW YORK POST"
READS RUSH HOUR.
THOUSANDS WAIT UNTIL THE BORDER
WILL BE PUT WIDE OPEN.
MOST PEOPLE SHOULDN'T QUALIFY
BUT BIDEN LETS THEM IN ANYWAY.
OUR PANEL IS HERE NOW.
THIS WILL BE A LIGHTNING ROUND.
LET'S BEGIN WITH JOSE.
IF YOU CAN APPROACH DEFENDING
WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING RIGHT NOW AS OUR AGENTS
ARE SEEING A TICK UP IN
SUICIDES.
>> IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE.
JUST LAST WEEK THEY CAUGHT
1.5 MILLION PILLS OF FENTANYL AT
THE BORDER IN ARIZONA.
BORDER PATROL, THIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE DOING THEIR
JOB.
IF YOU WANT TO DO A BETTER AND
FASTER JOB PASS BORDER
ENHANCEMENT.
A BILL IN CONGRESS WHICH YOU GET
PASS, THE BUDGET HAS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS FOR BORDER
ENHANCEMENTS.
IF REPUBLICANS CARE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION LET'S PUT MORE
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND.
LET'S STOP FINGER POINTING.
>> Harris: BUT JOSE, AGAIN WE
HAVE TO KEEP IT QUICK.
YOU KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM ISN'T
JUST POURING MONEY ON THIS.
YOU HAVE TO SLOW DOWN THE SURGE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE 18,000 PEOPLE
PROJECTED A DAY COMING OVER WHEN
TITLE 42 GOES AWAY IN EIGHT
DAYS?
>> INSANITY.
WHAT BILL MELUGIN SHOWED US IS A
COMPLETE DERELICTION OF DUTY BY
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
WHAT HIS POLICIES HAVE DONE,
FISCAL YEAR 2022 WE SAW
2.7 MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW
OF COME HERE.
FISCAL YEAR BEFORE THAT
1.7 MILLION THAT WE KNOW OF.
A YEAR LATER YOU HAVE A MILLION
MORE PEOPLE NOT TO MENTION OVER
100 PEOPLE ON THE TERROR WATCH
LIST THAT HAVE BEEN CAUGHT THAT
WE KNOW OF.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
SHOULD BE A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
IT TAKES A PRESIDENT WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM.
NOT SIMPLY A CHALLENGE.
IT IS IMPACTING THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN YOU ARE
COUNTRY'S HISTORY IN A 12 MONTH
PERIOD WE'VE SEEN OVER 100,000
AMERICANS WHO HAVE OVERDOSED
FROM THE USE OF DRUG.
FOR ANYBODY TO SAY ANYTHING
OUTSIDE OF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON
IMMEDIATELY IS GAS LIGHTING AND
LYING TO US.
>> Harris: GENTLEMEN, I HAVE TO
LET YOU GO BUT WHEN WE COME BACK
TOGETHER AGAIN, LET'S TALK ABOUT
TITLE 42.
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE -- THEY
COULD MOVE THAT DATE.
THE WHITE HOUSE COULD DO THAT.
MAYBE THEY'LL DO THE RIGHT THING
AND PUSH IT BACK TO STEM THE
TIDE WHILE WE CATCH UP AND MAY